today on the matt wall show disney ramps
up its efforts to trans our children
with a new children show featuring an
appearance by a menstruating man also
the january 6th hearings continue and
will never stop for all eternity plus
aoc unveils the new plan for evading the
supreme court's road decision and a 29
year old father of three beats a 13 year
old girl in a women's skateboarding
competition and that's not even the most
absurd part of this story wait until you
hear the rest all of that and more today
on the matt walsh show
[Music]
you know life happens fast and it can
end even faster you picture yourself
living to a ripe old age but then you're
you know just walking down the steps
thinking about how long your life's
gonna be you trip over something on the
steps you tumble down break your neck
and you're dead you're gone could happen
to anyone at any time you simply just
die people die we all die it's going to
happen eventually and when that happens
you want to have a plan in place
otherwise the state the people you hate
the people who are trying to
indoctrinate your kids take your guns
steal your freedom they're going to step
in and take control of your assets when
you're gone they're going to determine
what legacy you leave behind don't let
the state decide what happens to you or
your children um should something happen
you instead take five minutes and set up
a will through epic will starting at
just 119
you choose who raises your kids you
choose who gets your useless crap after
you're gone here's what i want you to do
go to epicwell.com use promo code walsh
you get a 10 discount on epic will's
complete wheel package that yes could
take only five minutes to set up many of
our families at daily wire are now
protected thanks to epic will why don't
you do the same you got to do this now
because when you're tumbling down the
steps to your certain doom is going to
be too late then to sign up for epic
will you can sign up for epic will very
quickly but not that quick so go to
epicwhell.com and enter promo code walsh
and do something for you and your family
today
the most talked about interview in my
film what is a woman which is available
to stream what is a woman dot com by the
way is probably the one i had with dr
michelle forcier uh this at least is the
interview that people ask me about the
most and usually their questions revolve
around how i managed to sit and listen
to her spew all of that insidious
nonsense without screaming or vomiting
or both and the answer to that question
is um well only by the grace of god
especially considering the fact that
forcier is not just a so-called gender
affirming pediatrician but also
an abortionist and the latter came to me
as a surprise i didn't know that when we
booked the interview with her
um
and we booked the interview because she
was an advocate and an enthusiastic
administer of chemical castration drugs
for children i didn't realize going into
the interview that she also kills babies
in the womb i learned this fact about
her when she listed it in her
introduction as i was sitting across
from her that was one of the many
occasions during the course of our
conversation where i had to exert great
emotional effort to suppress what would
otherwise be my natural reaction to
learning that about somebody
but looking back it's really not so
surprising
that somebody who kills children in the
womb would also be in the business of
transiting them a little later in life
the pro-abortion agenda
naturally and quite literally bleeds
into the trans agenda an unholy alliance
is forged between the two
and not just because the two together
have led to the total self-immolation of
the medical profession though that is
certainly the case because you know
because of abortion and transgenderism
now thousands of doctors have dedicated
their careers to killing destroying
mutilating abusing and exploiting
children both are multi-billion dollar
enterprises enticing medical
professionals to abandon their oaths to
do no harm and instead
do harm directly and intentionally for
profit
both are a complete inversion of
medicine and of healthcare
and together they have almost entirely
discredited the medical profession as a
whole how can we trust this industry
when two of its largest most lucrative
most uh public-facing branches are
devoted entirely to the demolition of
human life and potential
but this is not the only way that these
two issues are related more broadly
the abortion agenda and the trans agenda
both attack undermine
and attempt to erase the fundamental
dignity of human life
children are treated less like human
persons and more like objects to be
judged wanted or unwanted and then
discarded or used accordingly
alexandria ocasio-cortez recently posted
a comment from an instagram follower
and the instagram follower said to her
glad your mom didn't abort you and she
responded
thank you i feel blessed that i was a
wanted and welcomed baby and that my mom
wasn't forced to birth a child against
her will
wanted and welcomed
she makes this stipulation because
according to aoc some babies are not
welcomed they are unwelcomed guests to
human existence and should therefore be
decapitated or dismembered and then
tossed into a dumpster and forgotten
not welcomed
imagine saying that imagine actually
writing that about a baby
is it any surprise that people who feel
this way about human life about children
in particular would also be so
enthusiastic about castrating
sterilizing corrupting and sexualizing
kids
after all if they can't destroy the
child individually and personally then
they can always settle for destroying
childhood
overall the message from the left
from the message from the leftist to the
child is basically this you exist for me
if i don't want you to exist then i will
kill you
if i allow you to exist that i can do
what i want with and to you
you are not a person with your own
dignity and value you are a pawn in a
puppet you're an accessory at best a
blank canvas for me to paint whatever i
want on top of you are clay for me to
mold and sculpt into whatever hideous
shape i prefer
this is the message
and it's appropriate that um therefore
that while we're still in the midst of
the hysteria over the dobbs decision
the wheels of the child transing machine
continue to churn
these are not two separate issues but
rather different manifestations of the
same underlying cultural spiritual
sickness
and when it comes to trans and children
there are two developments this week i
think that are worth noting one is
biden's assistant hhs secretary rachel
levine the male who identifies as a
woman
coming out in front of cameras once
again to advocate for the mutilation and
castration of children listen
gender affirming care is life-saving
medically necessary
age appropriate and a critical tool for
health care providers
as a pediatrician when it comes to
making sure kids are healthy and happy
i know how important care that affirmed
someone's true identity can be
um ending abortion
will not save any children's lives they
say but sterilizing them at the age of
12 or chopping their breasts off at age
14 that will save their lives
this is the argument they're making
and the argument for transitioning
children
is supposed to somehow be even stronger
coming from a man who identifies as a
woman
except the opposite is obviously the
case left-wing trans activists are the
least credible voices on this topic
because they're biased by a desire to
justify and rationalize their own
choices
every defense levine offers for the
transing of children
is not really a defense of the
transiting of children but rather a
defense of levine
we cannot go to people who are so
personally invested in this issue
and expect to get a thoughtful and
objective analysis
biden has put somebody in charge of hhs
who now uses that entire government
agency as one enormous tool for
self-justification
that also explains what's happening in
hollywood and especially at disney
those leaked internal videos a few
months ago
show left-wing lgbt people at disney
demanding that disney
devote itself to justifying affirming
rationalizing and reinforcing them
personally and their perceptions of
themselves
disney of course has been tripping all
over itself to oblige which brings us to
another leaked video this one uh also
published by christopher rouffeau
showing a scene from the upcoming disney
children's show baymax
and in the scene we see a robot
wandering around the tampon aisle at the
grocery store for some reason which sets
the stage for this interaction watch
[Music]
excuse me which of these products would
you recommend
oh um
well
these are the tampons i usually use
thank you i prefer pads they're more
comfortable for me thank you i always
get the ones with wings thank you get
unscented and bleach free if you can
thank yo my daughter loves these i think
these might be easier if it's our first
period these are really environmentally
friendly
now perhaps it's good that the trans
propagandists are so allergic to
subtlety
because then it's never difficult to see
what they're doing
um and so in that scene we see a bunch
of people giving their personal
endorsements of various tampon brands
including
a man wearing an enormous trans flag on
his shirt
and it's worth noting i think that the
menstruating man in the scene
appears to be an actual man
you know in the context of the show he
he has the voice and build of a man not
of a woman identifying as a man
the character is obviously meant to be
an actual man a biological male
who gets a period and requires feminine
hygiene products
now
even without the menstruating male in
the scene it would still be weird and
gross and gratuitous and grotesque to
drop this discussion of tampons into a
show designed for elementary aged
children
but with the menstruating dude it
descends to a whole new level of
deranged
what's the idea behind it i mean why put
that in the show the idea of course is
to confuse kids
that's the primary goal of the trans
agenda it's to make everybody especially
children confused
it's not so much to give them
like a different idea of how the world
works
because they don't really want the kids
to have any firm ideas about these
things at all
just be confused
and that's it
one elementary school teacher on tick
tock this week i think made that
abundantly clear listen to
this a kid today
looks at me and goes
are you a boy
or a girl
and i was like
oh no what do you think
to what you said oh a girl and i was
like oh why do you think that
uh because you have a girl's voice
to which i looked at her and went
okay and what if i drop in an octave
and she just went
so you're a boy
and ran off
jamie confusing children since
who knows
you tell she's quite proud of herself
for managing to confuse a seven-year-old
now the child had the right idea to
begin with she saw this woman with short
hair and masculine clothing
and correctly assessed that in spite of
dressing this way and presenting herself
this way she's still a woman
the teacher took this clarity of mind
and intentionally
muddied it the trans cult wants kids
confused and lost and out of balance
they're easier to use
and manipulate that way and to the trans
cult in the left generally
that is what a child is from the moment
of conception
a thing to be used and manipulated
or simply
discarded
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well i don't know about you but i'm very
excited to travel this summer have you
ever thought about all of the people
that um make a vacation truly great tour
guides hotel concierges
bartenders friendly counter men you name
all the people standing behind various
counters being very friendly all these
people make vacations so much better you
know
outstanding talent is crucial for a
successful business and if you're hiring
you can find talent for roles like these
and more at ziprecruiter when you try it
for free at zip recruiter dot com slash
walsh zip recruiter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply additionally zip recruiter has
a complete suit uh suite of tools that
uh make it easy to filter review and
rate your candidates four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
that's how easy it is so travel to this
easy to remember web destination
ziprecruiter.com walsh that's where you
can try ziprecruiter for free again
that's ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
by the way i have to complain before we
get to headlines i have to complain
about something
petty for a second so par for the course
but top because i want to know
and you could tell me in the comments if
you've encountered this recently i've
encountered it twice so far in the last
like maybe month
and i'm wondering if it's officially
becoming a thing i hope it isn't but
here's the most recent incident i go
into chipotle here in nashville
um and you know walk in there's lots of
people not in lots of people there but
they're not in line and they're just
like standing around
looking at their phones
and nothing unusual about that i guess
that's everywhere you go in society so i
go up to order my burrito and the
manager walks over and says that they're
only taking online orders
he tells me i have to go online and
order it
and then they can make it like they'll
make it at that location but i have to i
have to go on my phone and download the
app and order it that way and then they
can make it and then of course i say
well
why can't i just tell you what my order
is i can't why can't i i'm talking to
you right now can i just tell you i'll
tell you what i want
and then he says well because we're
understaffed and he motions over to a
group of five employees just standing
around doing nothing
it's like so wait so you have the staff
to make the order if i send it to you in
written form online but not if i just
tell you
makes no sense like i said the second
time i've encountered this other time
was at starbucks at
an airport and uh so i just left because
i'm not participating in this charade of
like standing there i'm gonna stand
there in front of you and order it on my
phone while you're just standing there
looking at me waiting for it to come in
on the screen on the other side of the
uh
of the counter
don't protest don't submit to this
people don't do that
we cannot allow this to be a thing now
makes no sense at all
and that's a perfect transition into the
january uh the january 6th hearings uh
and i think it's a perfect transition
because both my complaints about
chipotle
and the january 6th hearings are petty
and unimportant although the chipotle
thing is certainly more important than
the hearings
and uh yet again they're the dems are
are trotting people out to give their
testimony
and they were making a real big deal
about this yesterday this is from cnbc
it says former president donald trump
lunged at a secret service agent in a
rage in the presidential limousine when
told he could not be taken to the u.s
capitol on january 6th 2021 this is
according to a white house aide
testifying cassidy hutchinson
tells this scene she had quite a lot to
say but especially the thing that's
making all the headlines is this scene
that allegedly occurred in the
presidential limousine where she says
that he was so enraged he wanted to go
back to where the riot was happening and
uh and he wasn't taken back so he
grabbed the steering wheel tried to
commandeer
the limousine and he also assaulted a
secret service agent in fact we have the
clip of her describing this let's let's
watch
once the president hadn't gotten into
the vehicle with bobby
he thought that they were going up to
the capitol and when bobby had relayed
to him
we're not we don't have the assets to do
it it's not secure
we're going back to the west wing
the president had
very strong a very angry response to
that
um
tony described him as being irate
the president said to me it's the effect
of
i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr angle grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle and this when
mr ronaldo had recounted the story to me
he had motioned towards his clavicles
okay so we have we have donald trump
assaulting a secret service agents
trying to physically commandeer the
limousine and uh there are a few
problems immediately when you hear this
story
and it's well the first problem is it
just sounds like total bs it sounds
completely bogus there should be red
flags all over the place when you hear
that
um
listening to her and other people have
been making this comparison
on twitter i think it's pretty good
comparison you're really getting amber
herd vibes you're getting um christine
blasey ford vibes from her it's kind of
like this amalgamation of the two and it
doesn't make any sense also just
logistically and when you if you're
familiar with the layout of a limousine
like he's in a limousine so
uh lunging
for the steering wheel would require him
to
like crawl across the limo
you know and then and then usually
there's a there's going to be a screen
or something there he's going to reach
across i don't know if maybe there's a
glass a lot of times there's a glass
kind of screen
in the limo so maybe he punches through
it breaks the glass
dives over
the driver's seat takes the the uh
the steering wheel that's the claim
anyways like something like that is what
she's saying happened
but there may be some problems with this
version of events just a few the daily
wire has the report former president
donald trump's lead secret service agent
is reportedly ready to testify the
testimony given by a former white house
staffer on wednesday to january 6th
house select committee is false
um
hutchinson claimed as we know already
what he claimed
nbc
chief white house correspondent peter
alexander tweeted a source close to the
secret service tells me both bobby engel
the lead agent and the presidential
limousine suv driver are prepared to
testify under oath
that neither man was assaulted and that
mr trump never lunged for the steering
wheel
so
yeah you'd say just a few problems a few
problems with that testimony with
everything that we're hearing and with
just the fact that we're still
going through this we're still harping
on it
listen i desperately
want to move on from january 6th
i think most people do
well i would say it's not that i want to
move on it's uh or that most of us want
to move on i wouldn't put it that way
it's that we have moved on
right most of us we moved on you know
when we moved on from january 6th on
january 7th because it's the next day
and so you you can continue living your
life from that point right
um i'm not living in a perpetual january
6th
uh this is not groundhog's day for me
i'm not bill murray in groundhog's day
january 6th edition and that's that's
the case i think for most people we've
moved on we're living our lives
especially given the state of the
country the state of the economy
we all have
more
pressing concerns in our lives
than this
and so i've moved on and i would like
for
um
dc to move on also
you probably agree
here's the problem though
if donald trump
uh runs and becomes the nominee
then i'm telling you right now the whole
campaign
the whole campaign season the whole
election will not be about biden it
won't be about the democrats failing it
won't be about the fact that the
democrats are making us poorer and less
safe and they're transiting our kids and
all the rest of it no it won't be about
that it'll be about trump and it'll be
about january 6th and it'll be about the
2020 election
and trump himself will lean into that
uh he will see to it
that the 2024 election
is about the previous election
because democrats they don't want to
move on
and neither does trump
neither of them want to move on
this is what they both want
and
from a political standpoint i can see
why that's the case for the democrats
now yeah the january 6 stuff isn't
resonating the way that they the way
that they wanted to
but
they want to keep talking about trump
this is just their way to talk about
trump and why do they want to do that
well because what else are they going to
talk about
are they going to talk about what's
happening right now no because it's all
bad
they don't want to talk about biden they
want to pretend biden doesn't exist
so politically it's a smart strategy for
them to talk about anything but
what's happening right now
and to talk about anything but
the guy who's actually in the white
house right now for the democrats smart
strategy it's really their only strategy
for republicans it's an incredibly
stupid strategy
incredibly stupid
okay because if you want to win in 2024
all you have to do is point around at
what's happening right now in the
country and say
look at this guys
is this good no it's not good but let's
let's have it let's have a change of
management
that's essentially all all the pitch has
to be
trump's not going to do that though
he's going to spend the whole time
talking about 2020
in the 2020 election it's all he wants
to talk about he doesn't want to talk
about anything else
you know as uh as ben often points out
you you lose an election if the election
is a referendum on you so whoever the
election is a referendum on
that person loses
which is why in 2024 you want the 2024
election to be a referendum on joe biden
you want every conversation go back to
joe biden that's who you want to talk
about is joe biden
we're not talking about what happened in
2020 we're talking about what happened
from inauguration until
until this moment
and i think you could even say simplify
it a little bit you could say that
you lose
right if the election is about you
like if it's just about you in general
um yes if it's a if it's a referendum
but if if the election is about you
then you lose and i know that uh
that you might come back
you your rebuttal to that might be well
2016 was about donald trump it was the
only thing everybody was talking about
and he won
and that's that's actually not exactly
true because the the brilliance of of
donald trump in that election cycle is
that he you know he actually made it
about hillary clinton even though he was
the phenomenon
and he's all that the media was
interested in talking about and there
was obviously a whole lot of enthusiasm
behind his campaign he was always
bringing it back to hillary clinton he
made the election
and in terms of people going to actually
vote go to the ballot box on on
on election day he made that about
hillary clinton
lock her up all the rest of it that was
about hillary clinton hillary clinton
which is a smart move and obviously it
worked
well in 2024 we need to think about
um who the election should be about
and very clearly you want it to be about
biden who's going to be 82 years old
full-on full-swing dementia
he has utterly failed in every single
way
he's made everyone's lives worse
everything he's done has been an abysmal
failure it's it's so far
the most incompetent most disastrous
presidential term in american history
and that's not an exaggeration
and that's all we should be talking
about
so
desantis 2024
is my point now that you know desantis
runs
the dems they're going to try to make
the election about desantis they'll try
to do that and that's great that's what
we want yeah make the election about ron
desantis because let's let's go look at
florida look at what he's actually done
in florida
okay you know he may pass the don't say
gabriel no one can say gay in florida
anymore without being if they say gay
then a drone flies overhead and executes
them on the spot yeah go ahead
let them go into 2024 talking about that
and making those kinds of absurd claims
and then ron and sansa can say yeah i'd
love to talk about what's happening in
florida
florida is the free state
florida is thriving while so many other
states are
you know uh decaying and falling apart
all right
so we've heard a lot from aoc this week
we already heard her on this show in the
opening monologue she's been all over
the place she's like an actress you know
with a film to promote in fact that's
exactly what she is minus the film to
promote so that's why she was on colbert
last night
and uh here's what she said another
another hilarious really funny segment
by the way on stephen colbert let's
listen
the supreme court has a power but its
power is in whether its rulings are
heeded and respected and if so how much
and to what extent
and when we have the framing of you know
the framing of our government the
presidency
congress the president congress and the
supreme court are supposed to be three
co-equal branches co-equal
none with supremacy over the other and
when any one of those branches
overreaches its authority it is the
responsibility of the other two to check
the overreach of of that of that
authority the supreme court has engaged
in the overreaching of its authority
in denying the human and civil rights of
any pregnant person or person that could
become pregnant in the united states of
america they have engaged in overreach
and it is the responsibility of the
president and congress to put the
supreme court in check because they have
de-legitimized them
this is what stephen colbert is doing
now this is his whole week of shows he's
just bringing politicians on to talk
about
abortion
that is the comedy
that's the week of comedy shows that
stephen colbert is putting together
pretty amazing
um not that amazing so we you know it's
we live in a post-comedy
culture in many ways so this is kind of
what you expect
uh of course everything that she's
saying there
makes no sense once i mean it just makes
no sense it's not even
on the premise even on the left-wing
premise it doesn't make any sense
this was the opposite this is the
opposite of everything she just said
the supreme court decision is the
opposite of that
she says it's overreaching claiming more
power all this
no
this is the supreme court getting the
federal government out of the issue
giving it to the states to decide
okay that's that's that is the opposite
of an overreach
when when a branch of the federal of the
government
says
we're getting out of this business here
okay we're we are pulling away from this
issue
and we're going to let states decide
when that happens okay
that is the opposite of an overreach
if anything if you really want to
criticize it from the left-wing
perspective then you should be saying
it's an underreach
okay they um are
underestimating their own power
that that would be the actual criticism
if you wanted to make one against the
decision
which there isn't a valid criticism
against it because it was a exactly
correct decision wonderfully explained
and argued but if you're going to
make an argument against it that could
even begin to make sense what you really
should be saying
what you mean to say is that it's an
underreach of of authority of
governmental authority
so
once as always it's opposite day with uh
aoc and by the way when i talk about
sending this issue back to the states
that is what the supreme court did
that was the right decision all of that
um
i say that even though i personally
like ultimately i i don't i don't think
that this is an issue well yeah the
state should just decide whether to kill
babies or not
um
what i what i think needs to happen is
that there needs to be a personhood
amendment to affirm reaffirm restate
clarify whatever
that you have a constitutional right to
life
that's what should happen
meaning that
as as a state you actually don't have
the authority to pass a law saying it's
okay to kill babies i don't think anyone
has that authority i don't think that's
a power that anyone should have i don't
care if you're your own state
there's nothing nothing nothing uh
magical about being in california that
all of a sudden makes it okay to kill
babies
so i'm in favor
and i think the entire pro-life movement
should be in favor this is not something
where we can say now the states are
deciding yeah we're we're good now let's
move on
they're still killing babies and you
have no right to do that the right to
kill babies does not exist
so i am ultimately in favor and i think
our what we need to do now is um is that
needs to be the next that's the next
step
is protecting babies all across the
country from slaughter
but that's not what the supreme court
did
they just got the federal government out
of the abortion issue completely for now
anyway
all right um
and here's this is also interesting
because aoc we just heard how this is an
overreach and everything and even though
again it's the opposite but here's aoc
giving her and we've heard this from
from many leftists this is her idea for
how we get around supreme court and
let's listen
i'll start with the babies of the
babiest of the baby steps open abortion
clinics on federal lands
[Applause]
a lot of irony to using the phrase baby
steps there
so didn't she just did we just hear this
stupid woman going on and on about we're
co-equal branches of government
and now you want now you want the
executive branch
to just usurp the supreme court ignore
it
and start start setting up their own
abortion clinics
and that like go to yellowstone park and
set up an abortion
um metropolis like a a mega store a
walmart of abortion on all these uh
federal land and on on national parks
so she gave that little speech about she
she wants the executive branch to usurp
the supreme court erase their decision
effectively and then right after getting
that speech she goes stephen colbert
says we're coequal branches of
government
meanwhile the media is running hit
pieces on pregnancy centers and there's
a point i want to make about this but
first let's play let's play go ahead
they're calling for these non-profits to
be regulated and demanding
accountability for a program called
alternatives to abortion which helps
fund crisis pregnancy centers in texas
they outnumber abortion clinics nine to
one when i say alternatives to abortion
what is the first thing that comes to
mind a waste of money wasted taxpayer
dollars lack of accountability
and
actually no metrics that indicate that
it has anything to do with averting
abortions
this is a program to make republicans
feel good like they're doing something
to help women does it help women
no
okay it is a waste of money
to try to help women in their
pregnancies unless you're going to kill
the baby if a woman is pregnant
and she's in a crisis pregnancy
which sidebar there
since the left is always
changing terms and labels for for uh
for things i should all note in fact
that um
crisis pregnancy centers don't really
call themselves that anymore that's not
the term anymore it's actually pregnancy
resource center
which i think is actually a better term
and this is a case of you know using a
different term clarifying the term not
to confuse people but to just use a more
accurate term because it's not ju you
know these these pregnancy centers are
not just for women who consider their
pregnancies to be a crisis it is for
those women but really it's for they're
not going to turn any woman away
so it's it is this providing resources
for women who are pregnant what we just
heard
from those two hags
is that if a woman is pregnant it is a
waste of money to do anything but kill
her baby that's how you can help a
pregnant woman is by making her
unpregnant through uh through
killing the baby
but providing her resources a waste of
money waste of time why would you want
to do that
and that is all that the pregnancy
resource centers do they provide
resources for in women
now
there's another point i wanted to make
here
um
because i'm seeing a lot of headlines
we know that pregnancy pregnancy centers
okay they're
they're stepping up to the plate in a
big way
even as they're being attacked on one
hand by these uh left-wing militants who
are setting their centers on fire
defacing them all that they're getting
bomb threats and death threats and then
they've got the politicians coming after
the media coming after them but they're
still stepping up to the plate meanwhile
we're being told all these stories all
these supposed sob stories about
abortion clinic clinics closing down so
the new york times uh on friday
said friday's ruling prompts confusion
and closures at abortion clinics there
was another headline about how you know
all the abortion clinics across texas
are shutting down all these abortion
clinics are shutting down right and
we're supposed to be very sad about this
now
for one thing i'm not sad in the
slightest
usually in most cases when i hear about
businesses closing down people losing
their jobs i am sad about that it's it's
in most cases i'm not happy about
someone losing their job
uh but
when we're talking about an industry
that profits off of killing off of the
mass slaughter the systemic slaughter of
babies
that's different now i'm quite happy to
see those businesses shut down everyone
losing their jobs they're now unemployed
i think that's wonderful you deserve to
be unemployed um if you've been making
your money this way but
this is a little confusing isn't it
because weren't weren't we told we were
told for uh unless i'm just
hallucinating and now maybe i'm was it
all a dream or something because i i'm
pretty sure that they told us for
decades
that abortion is only three percent
of what these abortion clinics do
especially planned parenthood they said
that abortion is only three percent of
what planned parenthood does
only three percent 97 of what they do
nothing to do with abortion
so why are they closing down now
all all roe v wade has done is in some
of these states it has removed
three percent of their business you take
away three percent
of
of their business and they just shut
down immediately
take away three percent of their
business and that very day
they're closed down
what how do you make sense of that
is my question
well you make sense of it because
nothing these people say is true they
just lie about everything and of course
they lied about abortion being only
three percent of the business
these abortion clinics abortion is what
they do or what they did anyway a lot of
these states
past tense
um this was their this was it
everything else
was just
peripheral really it was a smoke screen
all the rest of it everything else that
they do
the cancer screenings allegedly a lot of
these abortion clinics claim they do
cancer screenings they don't really
they'll give you a referral to go
somewhere else to get a cancer screening
but all that stuff whatever else they
did was all basically a smoke screen
um so that they could claim
that oh no we're just a medical we're a
medical clinic we do lots of things
no really it was abortion that's why you
take abortion away and they all shut
down immediately because they got
nothing else to do
and they're also not interested in doing
anything else
if they
when a woman comes in a pregnant woman
comes in yeah they'll offer a whole
bunch of other services
but the reason they do that is one again
is a smoke screen but also um they're
trying to attract customers
get them in the door and they have these
kind of loss leaders you know to get
them in the door offer some of these
free services because what they really
want they want your money for the
abortion
and they're trying it's basically trying
to establish brand loyalty
take abortion away not only are the
businesses not uh viable anymore
but they also have no interest in they
don't really care do you think they care
about providing cancer screenings to
women you think planned parenthood gives
a damn
if women get cancer and die they don't
care about that
they make billions of dollars killing
babies they don't care about anyone's
life
and that's pretty clear now all right
this was pretty funny gina darling is
the host of on g4 tv which i think is
that like a
video game network or something i don't
even know it still existed but
apparently it does
and um she's a host for g4 tv she
learned in real time
that the standard pro abortion feminist
talking points are no longer valid
so this is just i love this is hilarious
she tweeted on january 24th at 9 06 p.m
she said here we go she said if men were
able to get pregnant
this would have never been up for
discussion lol
um f this backward ass s
and then
hour two later
she
she follows up
after hearing from a lot of her
followers who are pretty upset by this
she follows up and says
oh wait pardon my wording not sure what
the proper wording is for this but i
guess
people born with male reproductive
organs if that's not correct please
educate me sorry if that came off as
transphobic
uh you gotta love that she learning in
real time that her entire world view has
been reduced to ash and rubble
by the trans agenda which she is
beholden to as a leftist
everything she thought she knew about
the world is gone and all of her ways of
engaging with issues and
talking about things all of that is out
the window
and she learned it in real time and is
now scrambling around
begging the trans activist said please
educate me tell me what i'm supposed to
say now
hilarious but uh
also of course rather pathetic all right
i've had this i want to mention this
daily wire report says old school
liberal investigative journalist matt
tayeby told ben shapiro in this week's
episode of sunday special that he lost
friends for merely reviewing
matt walsh in the daily wires
groundbreaking documentary what is a
woman we have a little bit of that clip
from the sunday special the whole
conversation is well worth watching by
the way you can go to uh ben's youtube
page and
see the whole thing but here's that part
of the discussion go ahead
i had kind of tried to stay away from
the issue i you know it's it's
complicated i i try to avoid issues that
i don't know a whole lot about
um but i had i had done a couple of
stories
that touched on this basically from the
speech angle
and i'd had a really unusual experience
i mean i've been a reporter for 30 years
now and it's always the same method you
call around a whole bunch of people you
ask them all what they think and then at
the end you kind of aggregate all the
opinions and figure out where the story
is but with the trans issue what i found
is i would call some people and they
would talk to me and then there'd be
this other group of people who would be
furious that you even called
would refuse to have any kind of
discussion would call you a transphobe
for even asking certain kinds of
questions and this is before you even
have a point of view on the subject
uh so i was you know i thought that was
odd um and then i had done an interview
with a woman named kara dansky who is a
feminist a gender-critical feminist
and uh
i it's not that i purposely shelved it i
just didn't want to deal with the
blowback that i knew was going to come i
i kept telling myself it wasn't the
right time
so i i felt guiltier and guiltier about
that as time progressed and when matt's
movie came out when one is a woman came
out i realized um i thought this was an
opportunity to kind of fix
the that problem of having you know not
run that interview so i did both at once
i reviewed matt's movie and ran that
interview at the same time and the the
response was unbelievable just for
reviewing the movie forget about what i
said about it um
you know i lost friends over that there
were there were people who who i've
known for decades who who have now
basically said that i'm a transphobe and
i i
i'm kind of out out of their loop now
simply for review for acknowledging
the existence of the film he loses
friends for that so it's actually
it actually takes
it shouldn't but it takes real courage
simply to
to acknowledge the existence of a film
that the trans activists don't like
takes actual courage um especially if
you live kind of in the world that
mataibi lives in
um
where you've got friends whether so
you're gonna actually sacrifice
friends because of it
uh and and also his um
his write-up of the film
it was thoughtful it was interesting
um he praises some aspects i mean he
does criticize other aspects of the film
i don't agree with his criticisms
obviously but he does criticize it so
it's not like a
i wouldn't call it a glowing review
necessarily he just kind of talks about
it he writes about it and and gives his
take on it and and all that that's
that's like that's what you're supposed
to do or especially if you're a film
critic that's what you're supposed to do
but i just went to rotten tomatoes just
to chicks i hadn't checked in a while
and so we're up to
over 5 000 audience ratings with a 97
score
which i can tell you
i'm a little biased but that's
impressive
to have that high of a score and still
now we're now it's four critic reviews
is what is what was what there are as
opposed to like most movies will have
dozens you know even over like dozens
and dozens of reviews
and um
these are not mainstream critic reviews
one is from christian toto who writes
for the daily wire another's from the
gospel coalition
and then film threat which is the
closest thing to a mainstream critic
reviewing the film and then a website
called synagogues.com that's it those
are the
film critics who actually reviewed the
film
all the mainstream critics
from the very beginning made it very
clear that we we all agree we're going
to pretend this does not exist
but it does you can go to what is
warm.com and see for yourself all right
one other quick thing before we get to
the comment section that i cannot
carry on with the show without talking
about
tragic news out of florida uh news 4
reports a young rapper from jacksonville
nehemiah spottam gotham hardin was
arrested in miami on sunday after trying
to elude police officers while riding on
an orange jet ski according to the miami
police department the 20 year old was
accused of risking people's lives and
property during the pursuit that started
near the miami marine stadium in
virginia key spotting got him best known
for the success of his beat box single
after climb to the billboard hot 100's
12th spot in 2020 um hardness facing
charges of fleeing and eluding a law
enforcement officer in reckless
operation of a boat
he also is wanted on uh aggravated
assault with firearm charges and
possession of a firearm by a convicted
felon now i'm sorry
but i don't buy a word of this
reckless behavior
possession of a firearm assault
does that sound
like spotum got him to you
you mean to tell me that the same man
who composed the heartfelt ballad
beatbox is also guilty of these crimes
i i just don't i'm sorry i don't
i don't believe it
actually let's just play uh a little bit
of that song because i'm always looking
for an excuse to play spot i'm god i'm
on the matte wall show a little bit of
that song and you tell me
if this story makes any sense with this
in mind go ahead
[Music]
how to stand off hit him in the spine
knock his dreads off my orders is called
her body
[Music]
box
you tell me that guy who looks like a
sideshow bob on methamphetamine you're
telling me that he
is a criminal
that's bottom got him outrageous
spot of gotham is a gender a gentleman a
phil a philanthropist a scholar a man of
dignity and decency
first they take down push isd
and now spot him got him
nobody is safe
nobody
let's get to our comment section who
makes a twitter mob fly off the handle
with rage
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
all right first comment says can someone
explain the sweet baby gang origin to me
i am a recent subscriber and i always
just get curious about it every time he
mentions it
we cannot explain it we will not explain
it and you're banned from the show
for even asking
uh
burns dumbs says sorry matt but i
believe that before a certain term 12 15
weeks whatever
a woman should be able to make that
decision because giving birth is just so
painful
you can't force someone to go through a
pain that you yourself will never
experience
okay well do you see the first problem
here you said
before a certain term
12 15 weeks whatever well does what do
you mean whatever you can't just
whatever so you're saying that you want
to draw a line somewhere
and i assume it's because you realize
that the idea of um
killing
a fully developed infant like five
seconds before birth is barbaric and so
you seem to realize that you're right
about that and so you want to draw but
but you also can't bring yourself to
affirm the dignity and value of human
life all the way from conception so you
want to draw a line somewhere but you
don't know where to draw so instead you
say you know just whatever we're going
to you can't whatever you can't yada
yada your way through that problem
that that's see that's because that's
exactly the point
if you're saying that up to a certain
point abortion should be
legal
um you need to be able to tell me the
point and the fact that you can't really
name the point
is itself the point
because either you affirm the value and
dignity the inherent value of human life
or you don't
and uh if you do then the only point
that makes sense is the moment in which
that human life comes into existence
which will be conception
um
if you're not going to affirm the
inherent value of life then then you
really are not affirming the inherent
value of human life at all and if you're
not affirming the inherent value of
human life then why should abortion be
illegal at any stage why should it be
illegal even after birth
these are all questions
that
you need to be able to answer
and but instead you just kind of wave
your hand at them and pretend they don't
exist and that's just that's just not
how this is going to work
um
math this song guy says
we will all be in mourning at the
cancelling of miss gorman so has amanda
gone the way of the panda
beautiful and uh can i say far better
poetry than anything amanda gorman has
ever come up with
veda tipple says i'm convinced that matt
walsh in time will be regarded as one of
america's greatest political cultural
commentators in time
so not right now
banned from the show
elise says my boyfriend and i got
pregnant after only nine days of being
with each other where we were homeless
drug addicts and our son saved our lives
we've been together for six years coming
up on august 1st my family are my rocks
my son is our angel thank you matt i
love stories like that and that's um
you know that's
you hear these kind of stories quite a
bit people that
there's a pregnancy that's at first is
is not what you wanted and then
you embrace that life and
uh and you are you find that your your
life improves because of it through
embracing human life embracing your
you know your vocation as a mother your
own life has improved in
in what seems like a miraculous way
you hear that a lot
and uh
you also hear on the other end you you
also hear quite a bit
people who do not embrace life and then
live with guilt and resentment and
regret for the rest of their lives
and finally bander snatched says as matt
danced he made himself so open so
vulnerable it's as though he was naked
before us
even and especially his face and chin
you're very close to getting banned for
talking about me dancing naked any kind
of bringing those images up at all even
to me is is just not okay i've already
banned two people so i'm gonna let that
slide and also you are affirming me as a
dancer which is what i am so i really
appreciate that tonight the western
world's greatest political and cultural
figures gather together on one stage now
i'm not talking about those old stiffs
at the nato summit in spain i'm talking
about backstage live at the ryman in
nashville usa co-headlined by yours
truly uh we couldn't wait till the
fourth so we're lighting the fireworks
early not literally inside the building
i mean that'd be interesting if we did
and you could catch the show in all its
glory on our live stream at 8 pm eastern
tonight by going to dailywire.com
ryman to give you a taste of what you're
in for here's a look at last year's
event welcome to the daily wire
backstage live at the famous ryman
auditorium
it was amazing we were in the presence
of greatness the energy of having
everyone on the same page was amazing if
your family member is still waiting for
fauci to give them permission to leave
their house it might be time to cut that
off
i'm actually pretty excited to meet all
of them i love everybody's opinion
individually i don't have a favorite i
like them all i had found out a way to
make football players cry in high school
my high school experience
i'm just excited to be here and be
surrounded by like-minded people
and to just you know feel that energy
who should we remove from office one
politician the most powerful politician
in the country dr fauci
we're doing culture here i'm so thrilled
to see this happening if they say to
half of the country you can't that half
of the country needs to say screw you we
will
so join me ben shapiro michael knowles
andrew clavin and the god king jeremy
boring as we dig into the political and
cultural issues of the day thanks to all
of you we're going to be celebrating
some big wins this year including the
release of what is a woman and also
terror on the prairie and if you're not
already a member we hope today that will
be the day that you join the fight and
help us win even harder so go to
dailywire.com walsh to get 25 off your
new membership as exciting as the last
year has been we're just getting started
so tune in tonight to backstage live at
the ryman to find out what's next the
fun starts at 8 pm eastern and you can
watch at dailywire.com
ryman
we'll see you there now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
well now that the floodgates are open
there is no limit to the madness you
tear down the walls which distinguish
inherently different things from each
other take fundamental human concepts
and categories and drain them of all
meaning remove the definitions of words
replace those definitions with vague
ambiguities and you end up with
unrestrained madness and this is all by
design of course
that's why we now live in a country
where over this past weekend a 29 year
old father of three took first place in
a women's skateboarding competition
beating out a 13 year old girl but don't
worry this story will get even more
absurd as we go along
so just sit tight and be prepared for
that here's the report from the daily
wire it says an adult biological male
who identifies as a woman edged out a 13
year old girl to take first place in a
women's skateboarding contest held new
york saturday the feminist site redux
reported ricky trace 29
won the women's division of the border
open for a 500 prize trace bested a
field of biological females including
runner-up shiloh katori and four other
children including ten-year-old jory
lacoura
uh quote mail wins women's skateboarding
finals and money at the border open nyc
presented by dc today tweeted taylor uh
silverman a professional skateboarder
who's been critical of biological males
competing in the sport now silverman
tweeted a picture of the top six
finalists and
if you look at the picture you can see
that second through sixth place
ranges in ages from 28 to 10
but what they all have in common is that
they're females that's second through
sixth place all females they're
obviously females
you wouldn't even need the names or the
context to know that they're females you
could look at a small thumbnail-sized
image of a female's face
and know immediately that she is a
female that's how clear it is
and that's why ricky trace stands out
like a sore thumb a man's sore thumb to
be precise
but i said this gets more absurd so
let's continue with the daily wire
report says
quote last year trace became the first
trans woman to attempt to qualify for
olympic women's skateboarding submitting
a virtual run for the usa national
skateboarding championships but the
biological testosterone reportedly
tested too high to allow entry as a
female under
the international olympic committee
standards
so
he could not qualify as a woman for the
olympics
but he did somehow count as a woman for
this competition in new york this is the
lunacy we end up with now that we've
disregarded biology as a determining
factor for whether someone is male or
female without biology we're left with
this
ridiculous situation where an athlete
might count as a woman in one
competition but not in another
this is what happens when you erase the
objective lines of distinction and
redraw them somewhere else anywhere else
wherever you redraw them it will be
necessarily arbitrary
so arbitrary that we're expected to see
this skateboarder as some sort of
shape-shifter inhabiting a male or
female body depending on where he is and
where he's competing
but we haven't even yet traced this
rabbit hole all the way down to the
bottom
things get somehow even more ludicrous
last fall ricky trace did an interview
with the usa skateboarding youtube
channel
and there he discussed the process by
which he discovered that he was a woman
after all not but a few years ago he was
a mustachioed father of three in the
military and now he's supposedly a woman
how did this happen
well here's what he says
i didn't know that i could even be a
female if i wanted to
it was just
it was i guess it was like something i
envied i envied females when i was a kid
i would
envy their dress choice they're
their like ability to be pretty and cute
and do things like that so how did that
go like how do you come out to your wife
about that and what's her reaction and
what is your guys status now
so it began it began with me
um
i had to i had to come out to myself
and that's that's kind of where all that
uh
say concluded all that guilt and regret
um
i had to i had to try to
justify it to myself like what is it
that i've i've been doing what am i
thinking who am i what am i like
um
it was it was tough it was a tough
justification
yeah that's a woman there we're told you
just feel the feminine energy right
but he envies women he says
and this is remarkable only in that it
was said out loud and on camera
it's entirely clear to anyone paying
attention that many trans activists envy
women and resent women for possessing
what they know they can never have
that's why they're so often so you know
nasty and spiteful towards women at a
pride parade a few days ago a trans
person was marching around half naked
with kill the turfs written on his chest
openly advocating for the murder of
women
par for the course among trans activists
now ricky trace doesn't go that far but
he does admit to envy he wanted to be
pretty and cute he says and later in
life when seeking to explain himself to
himself and to rationalize and justify
his own past actions he used that word
justify he decides that uh well he'll
become a woman himself
except not really
because the daily mail published its own
profile of this person and they quote
him as saying this okay this is this is
from him this is what he said
i am 28 i have three kids i'm married i
did my time in the military i own a
company i've decided that i like being
pretty and cute
so everything that goes with that is
female i love female bodies i think it's
a work of art
now listen closely to this part
i know i will never be a woman because
women are miraculous they have babies
and create life and do all that awesome
stuff i'll never have that ability but i
feel like i'm a woman
i would have wished to be born one so
i'll try to fill that image as much as i
can for myself and that pretty much
involves being as cute as can be
so he says himself that he is not a
woman and will never be one he simply
likes the idea of being cute
and he wishes that he was a woman so
he's decided to play the part that's not
my diagnosis it's his own i will never
be a woman direct quote his own words
now just think about this
we're being called upon to affirm
somebody as a woman even though he does
not affirm himself as a woman
we're being asked to be more confident
in his womanhood than he is
so this goes beyond the insanity of
being forced to agree with a person's
deluded self-perception in this case we
are meant to help him shape that
self-perception
he simply as he says likes cute things
and he's envious of women
it falls to society then to take this
raw material and form it into a shape of
a self-identified woman
also note that he's on drugs as part of
his transition quote unquote that means
a doctor prescribed him hormones to be a
woman even though he doesn't actually
think he is one
again it's not just about affirming
self-perception it's about shaping that
perception and then affirming it
society has now been given the project
of creating
new trans people of course the left has
been already doing that quite eagerly
for a long time but now everyone else is
expected to participate
what other conclusion can we draw from
the fact that we are expected to refer
to somebody as a woman and treat them as
a woman even though he only says that he
wishes he was one not that he is one
we're supposed to
grant that wish
except that it's a wish nobody can grant
because men are men and women are women
and ricky trace is today cancelled
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire